[Music]
welcome back everybody to another
exciting episode of the careful boys
well we got walter in the hot seat today
hi see walter
welcome to our game of thrones hot seat
where you know we like to put our
special guests in a very very very very
warm and hot seat and okay
ask you some really really fun questions
where we start off a little bit cool
sorry for a little cool and we'll get a
little warm and we'll heat it up at the
end okay okay i like to start it off
real sterile bart do i okay um what was
your favorite subject in high school
oh [ __ ] dude you're so good at that
that's a sterile ass question
nobody gives a [ __ ] but let's just start
that that's like let's waste some time
kind of quickly warm up you know like
looking back i actually remember all my
teachers in high school
and i i'll say history i wasn't good at
it but i like to teach her a lot yeah mr
reed i got a question so like for the
people who just tuned in who don't know
who you are
this thing like how did you get
passionate about stand-up content that's
true especially back then it was during
a time when asians had no representation
and you know it was still a time where
there was no
people that you can look up to and you
just had to just do it
for me so i have three stints in stand
up one was when i was 22 right out of
college uh one was like when i was i
think 23 24 and then this is the longest
one it's been probably close to like
maybe 15 16 17 years i'm bad at time
this one just started this stint just
started as a hobby
i just wanted to just do it just for fun
but for most people getting on stage is
like the most frightening thing in the
world though yeah for me i'm not wired
that way so for me getting on stage is
that was like i didn't it wasn't a
concern of mine even the first show you
didn't have like the butterflies like oh
my god i can't believe i'm doing this
[ __ ] i think i was more concerned with
like the very first time i did i just
stand up was at laugh factory waiting
outside for like 12 hours um that was
when i was 22 my main concern was is uh
are they gonna find me funny that was
like my main concern i wasn't like
getting on stage or anything like that
but wait so you had to wait 20 hours for
your turn well back then you had to be
there at seven in the morning
and then you went all day and then uh
they take your they take names at like
around like 5 30 or whatever wow and you
had to wait there and hold your spot
because if you left someone will come
across your name out and put their own
name in all other comics that's ruthless
it was bad back then now i heard you can
go like at four or five in the afternoon
and they just take the first 25 that's
it like no one waits they're just
checking online now yeah
virtual cue
back then yeah you had to wait what is
back then like in the 90s or like so i i
just graduated so this was 96.
damn that's when tupac died man damn
that means i gotta owe it to pk because
every time i had a spot he just hooked
me up i never waited or anything oh yeah
yeah yeah i mean they're they're people
that don't give spots to because
obviously notoriety and all that stuff
but pk
i will give it up to pika he waited so
basically when you go you do it and then
the owner will say okay he'll evaluate
you and he'll say okay come back in two
weeks so you can only go once every two
weeks pk went once every two weeks i
think two years damn i went once like i
didn't want to be a stand-up at the time
i was just doing trying it i went once
and he goes you're gonna be a star in
two years come back in two weeks coming
back in two weeks wait outside for 12
hours i'm not doing that i never went
back because i didn't want to be a
stand-up when they say come back in two
weeks you still have to get in line if
they don't like stuff to get in line
yeah so that's it's always been a casual
thing for you like oh this is a fun life
experience let me try it like you didn't
have this massive dream to being the
stand-up comedian no until i decided to
do it professionally which was about i
want to say like eight nine ten years
ago i decided i want to do this
professionally so you did years of it
just like for fun as a hobby yeah i
didn't write too much material i had
like 20 to 30 minutes of material but
then once i decided i want to do this
professionally then i started really
writing you had a job at the same time
yeah i was working in tv development um
at john walls productions like our
company produced er west wing third
watch
yeah so i had i was working there but
yeah i just did it as a hot i just did
this as a hobby and then when i decided
i'm gonna do this professionally then i
really just started like well what was
the most glorious moment of your
professional career so far
the the things that come into mind i
don't know if they're glorious uh
per se but like uh neil brennan
co-creator of chappelle show yeah i got
off stages that ain't good stuff and
give me a fist bump and then damon
wayans uh i came off stage like hey man
that was some funny stuff
so that to me was like it was cool but
like um glorious moment honestly like
i'm really shallow so glorious moment
for me would be like if like a hot chick
after the show was like oh my god you're
so funny it's like david wayne's yeah
but this hot girl
like that like yeah if she goes like oh
my god you're so funny can we go grab a
drink can i grab your balls yeah oh that
i well i don't even know what the drink
feels like balls i would probably just
die
it would explode
but yeah like if like a hot after [ __ ]
was like oh my god i think you're so
funny can we go grab a drink i'd
probably be in a situation where i
wouldn't know what to do you know like
i'm sure like you know my mind's like
you say yes say yes yes but then like my
heart's like but what if she hurts me
were you single you were single
throughout what if we get married and
then she divorces me
you're already thinking about that
one of my parents don't approve far
so during that stint you were a single
dude oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah i
mean when girls say they like funny guys
that's not what they mean they
like i don't wanna they don't want like
a hunk
when girls say they want a funny guy
when girls say they want a nice guy and
they say they want a smart guy that's
not what they mean like when they want a
funny guy they just want a guy that here
and there make some jokes that makes
them laugh like what you know like like
a make-a-wish foundation clown
when they when they want a nice guy pull
my finger
and then like nice guy they just want a
guy that's only nice to them
they don't want a guy that's nice to
everybody
yeah when they when they want a smart
guy they just want a guy that that
that's code four that listens to them
because if you watch them with dogs
they're like oh my god my dog's so smart
look he does everything i say
that's what they mean by smart guy
they don't want a smart guy
you know what like when bart says like
you know his mom said that black people
have that extra third lung
they don't want a guy that gives you the
biological
like anatomy i'm like no that's not
possible because of this they want the
guy that just goes honey what do you
think oh i agree with you that's a smart
guy
my guy's so smart you know he wears
exactly what i tell him to wear and he
just listens he's amazing he's so smart
that is a smart guy
so smart so like it's a misnomer what
they say they're trying to they're
trying to trick us yeah you know so guys
like oh i'm funny i'm smart
yeah what about the potentially the
least glorious moment of your career so
far the least is not getting booked it's
like that's probably like the least i
mean because for comics the main thing
is getting booked i'm obviously getting
fortune and famous you know up there but
like getting booked is like the stepping
stone to get to the next gig and what's
the definition of getting booked like
doing the local shows is that
considering a book or like doing the
ones where you get to travel anywhere
yeah anywhere getting booked i think is
like key because if we don't get booked
then we can't perform and we can't get
fans we can't you know get out there so
getting booked is key so like not
getting booked it sucks like in being
yellow if they if a club has one yellow
comic already like i
got beef with him well he's a job taking
that minority is what he is it's like yo
dude what he did coming back because he
he wasn't doing comic comedy for a while
then he came back and it's like oh we
got ken so we don't need anyone else
can't you just see where he's at on
instagram and you just go to the other
cities yeah but they'll say like oh we
got ken coming so oh
either way ken yeah i mean and uh that's
awesome for ken he should be getting
booked left and right he's awesome but
as a comic it's like yo you could like
not do comedy anymore like
have you tried that yeah that's a comic
you could just give up yeah you kind of
like made a lot of money and like hey
you could go back to being a doctor yeah
you're a doctor dude be a doctor you
have a lot of career choices bro hot
seat style who's the comic that you hate
the most in the game bam yeah ken jones
i love them but i [ __ ] hate them like
like this shock hates you like real hate
or how about this which i think is
overrated oh yeah oh dude that's a
little safer let's talk some [ __ ] log
into netflix
log into netflix they're giving those
away huh they're giving away specials
everybody log into netflix um so you're
talking about brandon's shop
yeah i don't know who that is i think
makes the point though oh no but but it
makes it
makes a point though do you think
there's a difference in prestige between
hbo and netflix when you get hbo special
and a netflix spec right now netflix is
higher oh
because of dave chappelle though huh
well all the comments that they signed
like you know amy even amy schumer like
the big deals they're getting um to me i
think it's great that they the guys that
the guys and gals that got netflix
specials awesome but i think it also
hurts stan comedy because then people
they're already paying for netflix so
when they're at home they're oh this is
for free yeah would you want me to go to
a comedy club and pay 60 to 80 they
don't appreciate it yeah and then the
comics like they're not even the good
yeah because they don't recognize them
recognition is oh it helps a lot
so when they're at home that this is for
free i could posit whenever i want and i
get the best people so it's [ __ ] the
comedy economy i think so i think so
personally i mean you're gonna have a
lot of like comedians that are like fake
intelligent
that's not me i'm like actually
intelligent
today's video is brought to you by
upstart tis the season of gift giving
but you shouldn't forget about yourself
why not give yourself the gift of
financial freedom with upstart upstart
is the fast and easy way to pay off your
personal debt with a loan all online
whether it's paying off credit cards or
consolidating high interest debt or
funding personal expenses over one
million people have used upstart to get
one fixed monthly payment with a payoff
date rather than looking at your credit
score alone upstart considers other
factors like your income current
employment and credit history to find
you a smarter rate for your loan you can
check your rate without impacting your
credit score in minutes for loans
between 1 000 to 50 000
you can even receive funds as fast as
one business day after being accepted
for your loan find out how upstart can
lower your monthly payment today by
going to upstart.com
off the record that's upstart
u-p-s-t-a-r-t
dot com slash o-f-f-t-h-e-r-e-c-o-r-d
don't forget to use the url so they know
that we sent you guys
loan amounts will be determined by your
credit income and other information
provided on your loan application go to
upstart.com off the record
has anyone ever stolen your jokes
um i i can i can say maybe a couple like
two or three but ken jong
jong
i won't say the guy's name but i'll give
you the initials
like the cm the like no ken's never
stole anything he's never stole anything
he's not a joke yeah he's not he's not a
joke um
it'd be difficult for me to argue that
they stole the joke but i'm of the
school of thought this is a personal
thing if i hear like a comedian do a
joke that's similar to mine i won't say
anything to them i'll just stop doing
the joke because for me i'm confident
enough i can write another joke yeah
that's just that's just my own personal
thing so i don't like if someone if we
have a similar joke i'll just stop doing
it like i don't care um but i need to
smash their wife yeah
yeah that's if she likes me which is
rare you know
she doesn't break my heart yeah because
she probably wants a smart guy that's
funny
[Laughter]
and then she'll break my heart and get
we'll get divorced you know
which comedy club in la has the nicest
owner
oh you know i gotta say um
there are comedy club owners where if
you don't know them yeah they're not
nice and i don't that doesn't mean
they're mean they're just they you have
to understand that they run into
thousands of people who are all trying
to kiss their butts yeah so there's a
bouncer at the front of the club exactly
so there's a wall to begin with but
having said that once you get to know
them honestly like i think uh jamie at
la factory is really nice really sweet
person um the owners of haha cafe terry
and uh jack is that in glendale uh no
it's a studio north hollywood studio
city they're really sweet people
um and most of like the
managers and bookers they're they're
nice people most of them not all of them
but most of them are nice um and so it's
just a matter of getting past the wall
because
and you understand why there is a wall
you know it'd be like when you guys were
doing just kidding films and all these
asian actors and actresses were like oh
i'm so funny i'm a comedian too i want
to do sketches you probably heard that
so many times it's like you do have to
put up a certain amount of walls because
chances are they're not funny
chances are they suck but they're you
know but you don't know but you do know
it's okay now
you know because you have to you have to
pretend you don't know and be like oh
yeah yeah i know i'm sure you're great
yeah like you know hit us up but inside
you're like i hope they don't hit us up
it's stressful saying no like to say
notice all the time all the time yeah
how do you deal with bombing on stage i
don't know what that's like
what's your worst bombing story
so when i started earlier what i used to
do is i used to rush through my material
because was it the anxiety of being on
stage or like what was what do you think
well like so at one point
my second stint i used to do my
character was a guy that owned um
a fast food
egg roll and wonton place and i had all
these different so you would play a
persona i played a character i played a
chinese guy like you know like i got
fried egg roll and fried wonton and then
not so fried egg roll not so fried one
time and then i would play all the
characters that came in i like a
southern guy come in a black guy come in
english people come in
the crowd was all british wait so you
played i played all the characters i
played everybody okay everybody the
crowd was british they just didn't get
it because is it an american joke i
don't know i guess americans were got it
but like the british people just did not
get it or they didn't like me i don't
know what it was but there was like
there's a small crowd like 30 people
like 20 of them were british
no one was laughing so i so what should
have been 15 minutes i rushed through in
about five to seven minutes
i just rushed through because like i
because where they're supposed to laugh
they weren't laughing so i just kept
going like i just it was basically i was
just reading off like a like a playlist
you know i was just reading that's
probably like the worst that i ever
bought and the whole time was our heart
pumping and yeah like i was just like i
need to get off stage were you sweating
a lot uh i don't
i don't sweat like that like that
doesn't make me sweat that's not your
fault that's like british people's fault
that's of course you
like while i was doing it i was like
yeah i was like you guys are so dumb
like why don't you understand this you
should have said that but yeah but see
back then though i was so like like
basically what happens when you well at
least when i bomb and you the anxiety
level goes up it's your vision starts
closing in it's like when you're drunk
and your vision starts closing you have
no peripheral vision it's just closing
and all you see is this that's kind of
like what was going on with me
but like now if a joke doesn't i want to
close in or just look at the exit side
that's basically like you know what i
wanted it to do
but like now like if the joke doesn't
work i just kind of like i'll give it
some like a couple seconds to see like
maybe they're not getting it but now
like i call them out like like oh like
so like i lost you on that one or like
you know you guys are dumb because this
is an awesome joke
i know it's awesome because it's work
yeah you guys are but like so now like
if a joke doesn't work it doesn't affect
me like it did before like before like i
remember when jokes didn't work i'd be
like really down
like i go through this emotional low and
be like oh man
i don't even know why i'm alive yeah you
know stuff like that yeah um but like
now it's like you know i i don't
i don't really go through all that
do you think like that's pretty normal
after like 10 years of doing whatever i
think each comic is different like the
best way i could describe comedians is
this like let's say you work at an
office job in accounting
you're going to have a variety of
personalities even though you're all
accountants some are going to be
outgoing some are going to want to stay
home some are going to be jerk some are
going to be awesome that's kind of like
with comedians too even though we're all
doing an extroverted activity
we all run the gamut there's guys that
get so nervous their hands are sweating
like crazy
like it's just you can't you have to
wipe your hands after you shake their
hand that's how nervous they get and
there's some guys that are like jerks
some guys are nice i've heard of guys in
canada that are racist they want to
fight you
to asian comedians yeah in canada the
nicest [ __ ] place yes
wow um and there's some guys that want
to be your friends and some guys that
don't want to be your friends so it's it
just runs the like regular human people
regular human people
yeah pretty much but i think people
don't look at us that way because like
oh because they're doing something that
most people can't do which is talking in
front of other people yeah so they think
like oh you guys are all wired the same
but that's not the case like we're all
we're all a little you know we're all
different we all have our nuances
there's guys that you become close with
immediately there's guys that you'll
never get close with just because for
whatever reason
um and so yeah it runs the gamut on all
that so we all react differently like
bombing or things don't work um some
guys you can tell get nervous before
they go on stage some guys aren't it's
just kind of you know so we reached the
16 minute 52 second mark of this episode
where we usually like to turn up the
heat a little okay get a little bit more
serious about what's going on yeah right
at that 16.52 what would you consider is
the most challenging thing that you've
ever experienced in in the game for
yourself
honestly it's it's getting booked that's
like the most challenging because for us
that's the gateway
is getting booked um whose job is is it
yours or the managers or like who's the
club it's everybody it's on it's on
everybody type like for like me
personally like i'd have it's me
reaching out to comedy clubs
and like getting no responses you're
just cold calling him yeah keep reaching
it's basically like hopefully it's
nerve-wracking because you're just it's
like a gamble and you're like i hope
they choose me yeah i hope they but it's
almost like a job interview every
[ __ ] week yeah without talking to
them oh man and then you just get picked
one oh you're just like leaving a
message they may not click your uh your
link
because they're getting they're getting
probably hundreds of emails from people
and then they're gonna see the ones that
they know
so this is gonna be a super naive
question but like let's say for like a
dancer right like getting booked maybe
is like going out to audition maybe
getting booked because you're casted for
something maybe choreographing for
something maybe dancing for an artist or
a car commercial like there's just
different types of things for like
comics
is there a multitude of different things
that getting booked like can cover
whether it be even like screenwriting
for a tv show as a comic or like or is
it just really like the avenue of first
like stand-up like getting popular
through that only yeah it's just like
when you're like so basically we don't
it's rare that there'll be an audition
for stand-up unless it's like america's
got talent or like some tv show there's
auditions for that but as far as like
for clubs there's no audition process
it's either like you know somebody that
like um referred you and they they book
you or you email them like call email
them and then hope and pray that they
click on your link and they like you and
then they'll book you and it's only for
stand-up now if you want to write
you know you've got to just write on
your own and then you have to go through
a different avenue to get and let's say
you get like successful let's say you're
like getting a lot of momentum and
getting booked for like standing like
what's is there like a a next what's the
next step concept for somebody like you
at least um
you'll know when i could when there's
like things that you like to do i guess
yeah like you'll know if i get to the
next level because i'll talk to none of
you
that's what usually happens on this show
when people big-time us you know you'll
know you'll everyone would know no uh
yeah for me the next level would be like
like big money big money i feel like i
mean at the end of the day for
entertainment no matter what anyone says
i'm too cynical to believe that money is
not involved like when people want to be
actors and you ask why do you want me to
oh i love acting i'm so passionate about
acting then be a [ __ ] theater play in
a small town you know what they'll say
there's no money there so you want money
you want money but with acting less than
one percent of the screen actors guild
union makes all the money
and that goes with pretty much
everything in entertainment it's like
one percent make the money and so for
comedians it's about getting booked and
it's about money
and so if someone comedian says no i
love it for the passion i i believe you
i believe you do love telling jokes for
the passion i love telling jokes i love
making people laugh i'm passionate about
it however
if there was no future of like a big
payout or big payday i think like 80 70
to 80 percent of comedians would stop
being comedians unless they really have
a day job that they crush it
professionally yeah and then like a
hobby like for you most of your years
was like a hobby thing right yeah yeah
yeah but yeah it's if money wasn't
involved um
i think a lot of people wouldn't do it
because why because there's a lot of
pressure in joke writing
um if it doesn't work
because you you pull your heart into it
if it doesn't work you get sad
and you know and the people and then
people talk like oh yeah i've seen
walter dude he sucks man but it may have
been one bad show yeah but they're gonna
use that one bad show and kind of like
pretty much like assume yeah well i suck
but then they but what they don't
realize is like some shows we're just
trying stuff out yeah you know we're
just we're just like saying i'm gonna
see if there was sticks and then they
they came to that show they're like i
saw walter dude like no one was laughing
that guy sucks is it like
everyone's kind of work shopping on the
weekly at these clubs and then
when they get a special that's when they
all the ones that they worked out that's
like the feature film like that's like
the writer's room the comedy club is
some material that for sure is going to
make them laugh but then their working
material they mix in yeah like so okay
this is the funny part with comedians is
that
we're working towards technically we're
working towards nothing
if you think about it we're just we're
we're doing shows and we're making
people laugh but a lot of comedians have
this and like do every time i go to show
like you describe joe i'm working
towards my special and then if you ask
them oh you have a special you know
coming along oh no i'm just being
prepared i'm preparing myself so
basically when you look at it
technically we're working towards
nothing they're working for imaginary
space imaginary special like we're
working towards nothing unless you're
like a big name and you've got a three
special deal then yeah when you're at
the club that guy's literally like dave
chappelle will literally be doing
material to see what to put into a
special and to work it out but like
someone like me or like i call ourselves
the mid-level like the working community
working communities where there's we
have no special in the pipeline in the
in the works and so when when a comic
like in the middle of says oh i'm
working towards my special it's like oh
you got a special coming out well yeah
i'm gonna shoot it myself okay well
that's a little bit different than like
getting a traditional special so
you know to me i don't i don't i guess
it's a personal thing i don't work i
don't write jokes or like perform
towards a special because i don't
nothing in the works i'm just working
for well tonight i'm going to make
people laugh hopefully and that's my
enjoyment from it but like there's a lot
of comics it's very business oriented
like i'm working towards i'm like i'm
gonna try these jokes i'm gonna put in
my special
like what what's special are you doing
bro and like you know and so and if that
but for them that's what motivates them
then cool that's the thing
but yeah basically you know i i do jokes
you know we want to get a certain amount
like 30 minutes an hour like we want
that
but i don't do it to be like oh i it's
for my hour special i'm gonna do i do it
just so like i know like depending on
the show if these jokes aren't working i
know like okay well i can hit him with
like something else you know like
because like i do a lot of jokes being
single
and if it's all like people that don't
care about being single like older
people
i gotta do something else because for
them they don't care about being single
if they're like reading the room is the
mastery huh yeah but it's it's the
mastery and also being having the
material like a wide range of material
to connect with people that's um also
key too um
so there's a lot involved um with it wow
man well kudos to you because stand-up
comedy is yeah it's brutal hard it's one
of those i think it's one of the hardest
things in entertainment to be good at
yeah just like dancing you know like
because like the play out is like i
don't expect you to be good bro i think
that sucks yeah i was testing material
on abdc you know
how'd that go
[Music]
do